children who are hungry extreme poverty
in this country orange to the conscience
of our nation let me talk about what's
happening in America and that is poverty
Americans have long been aware of the
country's poverty problem about one out
of every six people that you pass could
be living in poverty
almost half people United States living
in poverty but the nature of the problem
and even the scale of it seems far from
clear I produce documentary films here
at the Economist
and I want to get to grips with the
story behind American poverty fifty five
years ago they declared this one poverty
and they haven't solved it
if you earn less than about $24,000
household yes you are considered to be
in poverty but the way that poverty is
officially calculated in America is
really flawed it's now Georgia and her
most effective rare you know
kids are born into poverty then they
find it very hard to escape poverty and
if there are more children born into
poverty then you're not going to be able
to fix that where do we go next data so
I think our first thought would be
speaking to address
of the Idrees kowloon is the economist
US policy correspondent over the past
few months he's traveled all over
America learning about the current state
of poverty in the country and putting
together our most detailed ever
reporting on the topic what was the most
striking thing when you were so putting
the report together like you live in
here rabbit hole for so long and you
feel like you've only scratched the
surface
I was shocked that like you still see a
share in the population that is just
like really really deprived it's
different from the way that I think
we've actually doing a poverty sync
today we think of it as an inner city of
largely black phenomenon and like that's
just not just not the case that's
certainly still exhibits pockets of it
exist but I did know that for poor kids
for example like life chances change so
the sort of overall message is that
absolute poverty has declined since the
60s but poverty is still getting worse
for some areas it's getting worse
because it's becoming a lot more
concentrated and that has pretty
negative consequences for people
especially children this is the official
measure of poverty in America in 2019 if
the income of a family of four slips
below twenty five thousand seven hundred
and fifty dollars the government
considers them to be poor that seems
clear enough but it only tells part of
the story here's the problem that this
figure it's based on a 55 year old
analysis of 63 year old data in 1963 a
government statistician calculated that
the average family could spend a third
of their household budget on food
[Music]
but today only 1/8 of household income
is spent on food instead childcare and
housing are the biggest costs but the
poverty line takes neither of these into
account it's also the same wherever
people live in America which assumes
that living costs the same everywhere
and they're not and then there's this
compared to some other developed
countries America's poverty lines seem
surprisingly low in Britain families are
classified as poor if they earn less
than 60% of the national median the
midpoint for household incomes for the
entire population in America the line
equates to just 26% another clue that
the real story is not this simple
currently 6 a.m.
at Heathrow Airport that's what a flight
to Chicago reduces report is very
detailed and full of lots of stats and
at graphs and data but I think the real
way we're going to be able to find out
what the situation of poverty is an
America that matters if we don't that
we're going to put addresses special
reports and other research materials on
our website just click on the info card
on the top right of your screen to take
a look
[Music]
we are currently on our way to work
again which is a suburb north of Chicago
we were headed there to learn more about
a charity that provides support for
struggling families take this piece of
paper to the next table they'll get you
a pink bag and they'll get your diapers
and to meet with a few of the families
that the charity helps out
Lydia is a mom of two teenage kids and
one-year-old Raya was all these people
in your room we can play with like
others we met in this neighborhood Lydia
doesn't have a regular job childcare
here cost more than the wages she can
earn he is a general manager for a fast
food chain he just got promoted and so
you said that things could be a bit
strapped sometimes but you know what you
mean by that you know we're all just so
behind and playing catch-up is just
really hard we do end up going to like a
food pantry so our monthly income gets
paid every week so two of those weeks we
have to save or rent those other two are
going to bills my husband has to have
his phone for work so we have to pay for
the phones we don't have a landline and
we have to have internet because my kids
have either a laptop for school or like
an iPad for school they don't use books
anymore so they need to have internet to
do their homework you know we want to do
everything right it's just really
difficult is interesting because I think
the perception of what poverty is is
actually quite different from the
reality you can be poor but you can
still have two cars you can still have a
TV you can have a washing machine and
dishwasher you wouldn't
look at the neighborhood and think oh
god this is a really
and you can see that kind of desire for
the kids to do well to be educators and
go
to be able to live in a slightly
different life
but you know as we know from our
research that that's hard and a few
you live in a poor neighborhood it's
quite hard to break out of that cycle of
poverty hi Lauren
how we can't hear you Lauren Jones is an
economist who studies how social policy
affects children and low-income families
it seems to me that the people for whom
it's not necessarily getting worse but
it's sort of teetering on the edge of
the people who earn you know above what
the federal poverty line is thirty forty
thousand dollars and because their
chances of slipping in a much higher yes
I think probably sure I think the
dissemination of income growth has
really affected those people combined
with the fact that there really is no
support for people who are kind of in a
not working for range there's this kind
of group of earners who are earning more
than like 30 or $40,000 a year it's not
a lot of money especially in some of the
big cities talk to our affordability
this is a major issue that needs to be
addressed other rich countries have
implemented child benefit programs that
have helped to reduce poverty these are
for cash payments to all families with
children with higher benefits for poorer
families but could that happen in
America we went to talk to John Prado
the economist us editor in the report a
jury suggests that a universal child
benefit it would be the most successful
way of getting children out of poverty
yeah I was struck by how inexpensive it
was actually yeah and if you're looking
to spend money on kind of improving the
lot of poor people you are far better
off doing that and say subsidizing
people to attend college or a lot of the
other things that people talk about that
they could do more
yeah so my feeling is he or she ought to
be alert by the evidence the evidence is
it's not that expensive and it has a
massive effect pretty persuasive to me
yeah okay it's not very American
no you're right it's not but in some
sense Universal benefits are easier to
sell electoral either because everyone
gets them whereas if you're saying okay
this benefit only goes to this group of
people here that tends to be a much
harder sell make sure Mackey's Pro like
which yeah that tends to be pretty
unpopular in the sense of like what this
groups getting special treatment why
should they get it why shouldn't I so I
think Universal ones can be it can be a
kind of it
it's a easier sell in some sense right
now though America still faces major
challenges in tackling the changing face
of poverty we've made another film that
explains more about those challenges and
why organizations like this diaper hand
out charity are still vital
morning do you have your ID thank you
we've had clients come to us that have
said I've rinsed out a diaper and I've
reused it
I've turned a diaper inside out and I've
reused it
sometimes I've left my child in a diaper
for far longer than I should have
you can find out more about the diaper
project and watch the rest of that film
by clicking on the link opposite the
other link will take you to some of the
resources we use for making this film
including the special report on poverty
in America thanks for watching
[Music]